last week I put up a video that was
filmed here at the Cambridge Centre for
computing history and focusing to like
the video but a few comments made it
clear that there was a slight problem
and it was a problem that made me really
angry with myself
there was a very subtle high-pitched
noise in the background of a video and I
hadn't noticed it before uploading so I
thought I should explain why first why
the noise was bare at all and second why
I didn't notice it this museum is filled
with old computers with cathode ray tube
screens CRTs some of these screens have
specialized computer monitors but others
like these over here are basically just
old school televisions at the back of
each monitor is an electron gun it fires
out a beam of electrons wherever they
hit the phosphors on the screen light up
but the electron gun doesn't move at all
it couldn't possibly move fast enough
instead it just fires in one direction
and electromagnets bend the beam of
electrons the more power that's sent to
the magnets the more the beam bends so
for every frame of video that beam scans
the whole screen left to right top to
bottom I'm going to ignore the vertical
movement what we're interested in is the
horizontal inside there is a clever bit
of kit called a flyback transformer it
outputs a sawtooth signal to the
electromagnet which means that it ramps
up and then drops very quickly back down
and as it ramps up the electromagnet
bend the beam across the screen before
it quickly snaps straight back ready for
the next line that electron beam scans
across 625 lines of the TV signal 25
times a second so that flyback
transformer needs to ramp up and drop
down 15,625 times a second and because
of something called magnetostriction it
changes shape a tiny tiny tiny amount
every time it does that which generates
the noise at that high-pitched frequency
it's the same frequency that every
old-school TV produces at least in
Europe the numbers of America a little
different but they still end up at about
the same frequency now with modern audio
editing tools it is really easy to
isolate that frequency and remove it
until now I've been removing it from
this video but let me tell you it's here
and in this room with all these monitors
on it is loud
now I knew the sound was recorded
originally because I could hear it in
this room I knew my microphone was
picking it up I just thought the
automatic noise reduction stuff I use
would take care of it it didn't but it
also turns out these headphones that I
used to check audio aren't great at high
frequencies and so with my voice
drowning it out I just didn't notice the
sound there aren't many quite a bit from
that video I don't shut up and for a
while I was angry with myself because it
was unforced error I wasn't under time
pressure I checked through half a dozen
times I didn't think to check the sound
with my eyes that mistake might have
stopped the message getting as far as it
could but I think there was another
reason that I was angry
spider Robinson once wrote that I can
get is fear in disguise and I'm not sure
that's always true but it wasn't just my
headphones as you get older your range
of hearing starts to narrow it starts
yet more difficult to hear high
frequencies I know you pride myself on
how good my hearing was I can hear
higher frequencies now it's supposed him
for my age those 17,000 Hertz mosquito
alarms design to make teenagers go away
they irritated me through my twenties
and sure I can hear the loud
high-pitched noise here because it's
really obvious but in that video now I
have the strain to even notice it even
as some folks in the comments said it
was loud enough that they stopped
watching I did a hearing test I can't
hear
Mosquito alarms anymore I can't hear
anything higher than the use monitors
that video that mistake I made with a
sudden and sharp reminder that I am
getting older but some of the things I
used to do I can't anymore so protect
your hearing and next time someone
forgets to check for a high-pitched
noise in the background is annoys you
well at least you can still hear it